I know you're excited because there's
not 23 I can't I even I can't it's 23
people running for the Democratic
nomination for president
guys the me to movement does not mean
you're running me to 23 de Blasio in a
month I I can't or maybe it's a clever
scheme ed that probably clever scheme to
win in 2020 because the Russians won't
know who to hack it's actually the more
people get in it's better for the guy
who's at the top which is Joe Biden
Biden is pulling away which is ironic
because usually he's too close and
you're pulling away but you know what I
hope they get this right this time right
because elections have consequences oh
yes and the consequences are now coming
to a uterus near you oh that's right
for that's what this week was all about
the long game for the Republicans coming
to fruition now fetus and game would be
the movie we're seeing in red states a
lot of red states are having contests
with each other to see who couldn't be
more hardcore on abortion Georgia made
it illegal after six weeks
women don't even know they're pregnant
sometimes at six weeks Alabama made it
illegal at conception
Mississippi is thinking about making
illegal when you swipe right on tinder
Parker Arkansas now says any woman not
committing incest must start committing
inside if you cannot afford an uncle one
will be provided for you that's
ridiculous but no Alabama's not [ __ ]
around they put the dick in Dixie man
they their law bans abortion even in
cases of rape and incest how was he
supposed to get pregnant now about
gentle good humor that's what we do here
a gentle good humor but I tell you
liberals are not taking any of this
lying down they know how to fight back
at the Republicans with a hashtag really
they have a hashtag now boycott Alabama
which is great if you're a frequent
purchaser of fried green tomatoes or
meth I googled companies you know based
in Alabama and the biggest one was
Vulcan Materials the largest producer of
crushed stone that's right this is their
high-tech sector breaking rule breaking
rocks into smaller rocks but I wanted to
participate in good guy be part of the
boycott so I ordered today a truckload
of the crushed stone and that I called
back later and angrily canceled my water
it's it's it's infuriating because
nobody of course anywhere wants an
abortion but not everybody has the money
to have a child and raise one and bribe
it into college but you know be careful
what you wish for
there anti-abortionist because you know
there's a lot of young women in these
states would you stay there in Alabama
or any of these states that we're doing
this you know you've heard of the brain
drain there could be a womb drain come
out to California ladies the weather is
sunny and it's 2019 here
don't worry about abortion in California
you can get it done at the drycleaners
go over to the abortion hut at the
Beverly Center it's
but I'm telling you these people
criminalizing abortion could really
backfire on them I hope it does at the
ballot box this is the year or the woman
Oh code they said that last time so you
know but you know we have all the
slogans me too time's up
the new one all women should be believed
know all women all women should be taken
seriously women are human they didn't
forget how to lie in 2017 if you don't
believe me I have three words for you
Sarah Huckabee Sanders
as a public service now I'm going to
read the names of the states where the
abortion laws have become ridiculous
Georgia Alabama Kentucky Mississippi
Ohio Missouri Arkansas Utah those are
the ones with draconian abortion laws
these are the don't break a condom here
states and is if that's not bad enough
for the people who live there because of
Trump's trade war with China Walmart
today announced their prices are going
up and a lot of stuff we get from China
for example China make 72 percent of our
shoes so you did a Trump blend one
historic week and you're barefoot and
pregnant
you